will rain hell down from on high  [Music]  dear Lord let your Holy Angel be with me  evil may have no power  and in your hands I commend myself my  body and soul  congratulations on your command will  always be looking for you leaving  even if I'm a thousand miles away eras  going to Greyhound you'll now be out a  range of air cover for the next five  days  safe travels to England how many  crossings does this make this is my  first I got some most like they you both  kill distress rockets sir  we hits directly from the convoy the  Wolfpack hunters  you've out starter bail  in 48 hours we've lost seven ships  and fifty souls one of you did yesterday  data stood today enough  I'm not nearly enough  [Music]  [Applause]  target's disappeared sir  [Applause]  where they tom what are we gonna do will  rain hell down from on high  you